this show is brought to you by onnit.com
go to onit.com and use codeword church
to get 10 off of all of their great
optimization products alpha brain new
mood shroom tech immune stream tech
sport joe is a huge fan of the strong
bone this code word church to get ten
percent off or just go to joeydiaz.net
and click on the on it banner
go to nailed it life.com all you oil and
whack smokers out there for the premier
vapor pen on the market
use codeword joey diaz to get 20 off of
your order
go to hit ecigs.com that's hit letter
esigs.com
better tasting longer lasting a lot of
people are sending in pictures on
twitter they're getting it they're
liking it so please go check it out the
proof is in the vape e-cigarettes and
e-cigars for you different levels of
nicotine in both and the e-cigarettes
come in multiple flavors if that's
something you're interested in
use code word joey's church that's
joey's church
to get 20 off of your order
and go to irondragontv.com
iron dragon tv is a brand new roku
channel i just set up my new roku
yesterday i finally got rid of cable
i've checked out iron drag and tv's
offering they have a ton of martial arts
movies
like i don't think you could ever if you
sat down and watched them i think
it would take a while to get through
them they have all the cool jackie chan
stuff before he came into america
they're gonna have 4k technology they
have the in-man series use codeword joey
to get two free rentals
oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you asking yourself
it's monday
it's cold out snow's coming down
whatever it don't matter you're a
[ __ ] marine [ __ ]
wash your [ __ ] nuts out of them and
get out there and let these
[ __ ] know who's running
sit there like a [ __ ] mutt play that
glee kick that [ __ ]
what are you gonna do sit there get up
write your goals [ __ ] for the
month the year and the week and the day
get up get out there get the knife
whatever the [ __ ] it is polish the blood
off
you're getting some new blood on that
[ __ ]
let's do this
have you seen the music video for this
it's [ __ ] crazy but there's a dude in
the background of every shot just like
not in his head and i could do that
that's what black people do no he's
white he's a white dude whatever he's
confused you know what i'm saying i'm so
glad you brought it up how how amazing
does it feel putting powder on your nuts
i love it it's the best feeling i don't
need it as much anymore now i've lost a
little bit of weight but i still i still
have a powder you're rough against the
jeans and [ __ ] you don't make that noise
it's [ __ ] monday it's a beautiful day
to be alive
we're back it's the second week of the
year you know what the [ __ ] what do you
need
all they need is you just looking on
twitter five people got shot at a chris
brown concert when the [ __ ] are you
people going to realize standing [ __ ]
away from that kiss of death
because that's exactly what that
[ __ ] is he was at my gym for a
second he's the kisser yeah
how the [ __ ] building didn't blow up
is beyond me five people chris brown
just has this [ __ ] thing even when i
see him i'm like
that guy
i don't know what the [ __ ] his deal is
you know again five i don't know what
the [ __ ] the story is but if you bring
why would you bring a gun to a chris
brown cons unless you're gonna shoot him
that's what i'm gonna shoot his [ __ ]
chris brown right in the [ __ ] neck
what the [ __ ] it's monday you know what
i'm saying you gotta start the week off
good i might as well shoot shoot [ __ ]
serious brown in the neck whatever right
in that [ __ ] tattoo and a stupid
[ __ ] neck
what's happening you beautiful people
had a great time saturday night you came
to the melrose improv
thank you very much we had a great time
we was there with the girlfriend uh
there were a lot of cool people there
yeah einstein from 10th planet culver
city uh
my man uh what the [ __ ] his name
alder renee was there
uh who else was [ __ ] i mean all
different tent planet van nuys oh he was
there hassan has been
from gmack i mean there was just some
[ __ ] renee and carcione he's probably
at disneyland yesterday said it was
raining he flew in from new york with a
girl he's just like [ __ ] i'm taking a
vacation yeah that's how you do it and
then didn't someone else come from like
australia and then england there's some
people there so it was cool i got stoned
as [ __ ] i ate some stars we need to
start david this morning did you eat
italy of course i did you [ __ ] me i
was watching you watch me
like until until i stopped chewing you
like you're you're watching me but
you're not watching me i gotta watch you
like a hawk [ __ ]
you know uh when i do these shows now i
feel different you know
on stage and i feel different when i'm
there and i gotta taste them it's a good
time for comedy right now
it's a very good time for comedy if you
live in the la area
and you've stopped by the comedy store
it's a good time for [ __ ] comedy you
know at the improv the other night it's
a good time for comedy when i'm at the
laugh factory it's a great time for
comedy you know uh
it's something's different it's like the
good guys won finally you're not
watching the [ __ ] that comedy central
puts out and all these other [ __ ]
stations put out you know network you're
watching the underground [ __ ] come out
now the [ __ ] that people wouldn't talk
about and it's all through twitter and
social media and it's coming out on the
network now like little extra was just
on tv they have already on tv next
friday something man uh
right now the funniest guy working is
sebastian maniscalco i haven't seen him
a tight close second is ari sophia
i'm telling you this right now guys i'm
not telling this is my friend i'm
telling you that the material that
ahri's throwing right now about biggie
and going to china and taking the [ __ ]
it's some of the funniest [ __ ] i've ever
heard in stand up and i'm not telling
you guys this is
he's my buddy i love him to death but
i'm really proud of him he tore it up in
las vegas that night with rogan i was
sitting there going what the [ __ ] am i
going to come up with
because this guy's killing him he was
killing him killing them killing him
killing him so
you know bill burr is out there now i
mean it's just so his special for me is
friday night all right yeah i think you
can buy it pretty soon on his website
okay but yeah you could he said
something crazy like he he shot like 70
minutes and only 40 something's gonna
get on tv so for five bucks i'm just
gonna go and buy it and get the whole
seven day that's friday night on comedy
central
yeah i think it's the 11th or 12th and
it's like that night at midnight so it's
saturday morning no no it's not the 12th
and it's friday okay it's friday the
16th yeah let me check it on the 17th
we're doing
the uh riot
i like riot comedy festival right and
i'm doing the show saturday night with
al madrigal i think tj milani
and it's called revenge the theme is
revenge which is [ __ ] perfect for me
and then his show comes out that you're
on
when this next the following thursday
night what well the i the whole season
starts it's like eight weeks i think
right i'm on the last one
oh really yeah i'm on the last oh cool
i'm like in [ __ ] april or something
like that but i don't give a [ __ ] hey
listen man no for our uh comedy central
does not even look at me for ari to go
to bathmate with comedy central i own my
[ __ ] life you know that's the type of
kitty is he just told him from the jump
he's doing it because he was there from
the beginning so it's the 16th minute
yeah you got to admire that because the
17th we're doing the riot festival
whatever the [ __ ] it is do you think uh
do you do you wish you had been on
comedy central
yes and no i just didn't like the fact
how they shunned me from the beginning
but listen man that's the beauty of life
some people like you and some people
don't like i never really
it made me work in a different direction
at least i knew that door was closed to
me
i don't want to live my life going ah
maybe
you know at least i knew that they
didn't want to do business with me it
all started when joe did the man show
and i came out naked running
they all banned me for that they kind of
like it was like a silent type man
yeah and years later they took a couple
comedy pictures from me they called me
in for a few comedy pictures
and then uh
my name's been thrown around for
specials or whatever involvement on
midnight and stuff like that
and they just said no you know flat out
so you know i hear everything yeah i
hear everything even when they're
working you know
this chapter on rev this thing of
revenge when all he called me because
we're doing this it was really weird
because it's going on in a weird part of
my life i'm trying to write this book
and i'm writing the book about the
rocket ship when i lived in that rocket
ship in 84.
and i didn't know until i was writing
the chapter about living in a rocket
ship and 84 on the way here i made a
left and i went down that alley and i
saw a guy sleeping out next to a
shopping cart yeah and i i kept going
like oh i wonder what if you know i i
said to myself i wonder what it feels
like tonight to sleep outside i go you
know what
i slept outside many a [ __ ] night i
slept outside in a car here in l.a for
about three or four or five months
and an 84. do you get any sleep when
you're sleeping outside i can't imagine
you get any sleep
it depends how [ __ ] up you are i see
if you ever been walking you see a guy
like dropped yeah and you gotta walk
over him like that guy just got tired
and fell
like that guy just said [ __ ] it you know
yeah you sleep you sleep with one eye
you got money in your pocket
you don't know somebody's gonna run up
to you and stab you while you're
sleeping you know if i'm walking down
the street and i'm a killer and i'm
looking to kill somebody i see a bum i'm
gonna shoot him right in the [ __ ]
foot you know something he's sleeping
you know there's no resistance if i'm a
[ __ ] psychotic person you know
and just sleeping outside just does
something to you you sleep a few hours
you sleep light i slept outside when i
was a comedian you know many nights i
had to take a bus somewhere and there's
a four hour delay what are you gonna do
hey you gotta [ __ ] sleep you sit in a
bus station you put your jacket on over
your head you put your money in your
front pocket you put your hand in there
and you put the bag next to you and try
your best yeah but there has to be a
difference between my bus is coming in
four hours and i got nowhere to go oh
our abs are [ __ ] lutely yeah
absolutely we have nowhere to go when
you
you know you wait for the heat from the
sunlight i mean i remember being on that
[ __ ] rocket ship and doing coke in
there like it's a a three-foot you know
someone posted a picture of it i thought
it was i thought it was horizontal it's
vertical it's vertical okay and it has a
couple of different floors and there's a
beam in the middle and that's how you
get to the top
i would just chill on the
middle floor just in case i had a p or
i'd pee off the railing
or whatever but you had a snort and a
three feet i would actually go in there
with booze by myself at night
and then i would hide like a blanket and
you know i do dumb [ __ ] you know
but i know what it's like to be outside
and it was november and december in
jersey that means there's snow there's
snow it's [ __ ] cold out
so
i thought about the rocket ship
you know i wrote it i wrote a general
thing living in a rock or something like
oh this nobody wants to read this you
have to describe what you were going
through
what it felt like at the end of the
night to not only come down off the coke
and get depressed but then you're
naturally depressed you're living in a
[ __ ] rocket ship yeah you know the
weight of everything was on top of me
but on that weight was a
a pain that i had had like
i was 21
and
i was just sick and tired sometimes
people just get sick and tired and i
always knew i want to leave jersey so i
came out here to see my uncle
and i came out to
to get you know listen life throws
curveballs at you
and then people throw a curveball at you
but you know your family's always going
to be there
you know
this last thanksgiving
i've been talking to my uncle since 2009
and this last thanksgiving we're going
to get together
and do thanksgiving we hit him on the
podcast we had him on the podcast
and the monday before thanksgiving my
cousin called and she said hey he
doesn't want to do it he wants to go to
a restaurant and in a way it helped me
out cause it got me off the hook i
didn't want to bring the baby down with
the turkey in the car and all that so i
started thinking about you know what
this is perfect
so he called next day he goes no i
didn't say that
so i said to him listen what i'll do is
this we're going to get to turkey we'll
eat here we'll see what you're doing
later on if you don't want to go out
with your girlfriend or your son we'll
bring some food down to you
well i called him that day he goes no my
son's here i'm going to be all right but
if you want to stop down later that's
fine too with the baby i go all right
so that was the week i had the the
vertigo
so we went out we took the baby out i
went back home and i fell asleep i had
verdict i laid down on it i called the
next day he didn't answer the phone he
didn't call me back i called him a
couple of times didn't call me back
which meant he was pissed off at me
christmas eve we get invited to my
cousin's house his son's house
he's there
and we're cool but we're not usually
cool he's not saying much to me so i can
tell he's pissed off over thanksgiving
which he he should have told me directly
instead of telling his daughter he
should have told me what was on his mind
instead of mentioning to his daughter
that his daughter told me and i just
lost you know when somebody let you off
the hook they let you off the [ __ ] oh
you don't have to be there sunday at 6
30 you're like fine often they call you
back an hour later no no we switched it
to 6 30 [ __ ] you i already made plans
[ __ ] you know so
i uh
you know maybe he's pissed whatever and
i'm dealing with like you know in time
he won't be pissed
so i give him a present christmas eve
now when we're there christmas eve
i noticed my cousin the female is
sitting
with the kids outside my cousin's okay
but i can tell there's always something
wrong with her she's got a [ __ ]
husband a boyfriend that's a cop and
there's always something going on that's
right i finally couldn't take it i'm
like well i thought you know marta i
came up here to be with you you're
sitting the [ __ ] out here with you you
know come on in talk to us and i go eat
something and she's like well i might
eat with my husband whatever with my
boyfriend hey [ __ ] he's working eat
something we're here you know we're
right in front of you it's like when you
go to get a restaurant somewhere you go
to eat pick up your order and there's a
[ __ ] person taking your order right
in front of you put that [ __ ] on
hold there's a live body with cash in
front of you right that's the guy you
talk to first there's the guy with cash
in front of you [ __ ] who's on the phone
if he cared about his food he'd get his
[ __ ] fat ass down here
okay [ __ ] that [ __ ] when you're
doing customer service you deal with
who's in front of you right [ __ ] that
homo on the [ __ ] phone i don't give a
[ __ ] about him in his lunch order he
probably wants hummus or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] anyway
so
i that's the way i go marty you're here
with your [ __ ] brothers
your dad your mom is here and you we're
all in the kitchen eating and you you
know so she got mad at me
because i said that do i go [ __ ] him
come in here with us you know
and she got pissed off and we hung out
for another hour and a half i had a good
time with the baby and my cousins and
[ __ ] were playing music and the kids and
we were laughing my cousin's wife and
on the way out oh good night and my
uncle like raises his hand like [ __ ] you
and and my cousin raises hell and like
[ __ ] you you know
all right i get in the car and whatever
i called them both the next day and
thanked them nobody called me back and
then last thursday was the baby's
birthday i didn't say nothing i get up
the next one i said my cousin wrote
something on facebook
but that was it i called it back to
thank you for acknowledging never called
me back i called her back that night
never called me back i didn't even think
about it until yesterday or that
yesterday
saturday morning
before the improv that oh my god
my cousin my uncle was pretty tight with
the baby
didn't call
and i go you know what
i'll tell you in my world
i might have a problem with you lee
but i'm still going to give paul her
christmas present right you know
whatever's going on between me and you
that we'll put that aside it's hurts
about her well i don't [ __ ] mind not
going to be friends with her because you
want to be a [ __ ] momo so
i go you know what man
this guy has no idea
that i've never ever ever ever in my
life wanted to kill somebody as bad as i
wanted to kill my uncle for what he did
to me in 1984.
you ever watched two fighters fight and
then after the fight they beat the [ __ ]
out of each other and they're bleeding
like like what's his name kotchak
you know he's got a glass [ __ ] eye
you think when he sees gsb he wants to
hug him and jump up and down yeah they
fought and yeah you gotta act like a
[ __ ] civilized so people don't talk
about you but deep down inside he's got
a [ __ ] glass eye he hates gsp
that's how i feel yeah like we never
resolved that situation of what the [ __ ]
he was thinking
i was a 21 year old kid you know
my circuitry was all [ __ ] up lee you
know
i i had dropped my faith in society i
had dropped my faith in religion i was
done
i was donely
so i go you know what i know he'll help
me out i know he'll be cool with me my
uncle he was always there for me growing
up
you know i wasn't the best person at the
time but it doesn't matter man family's
gotta take you in you know
he didn't pick me up at the airport he
didn't answer his phone for days
i finally had to go to the restaurant
hunting down i remember sleeping out in
front of the restaurant spending the
whole night
sitting on [ __ ] uh whatever western
boulevard whether that is vermont
boulevard and all the way in hell down
there
and sleeping is finding this restaurant
with a duffel bag getting up in the
morning the restaurant oh me calling his
house spending quarters in those days
every time the answer machine picked up
you lost to 30 cents
oh no for the 25 cents you know it was a
[ __ ] night manly
finally shows up like a three with some
[ __ ] chubby mexican chick with a
smile on his face he's like oh you
showed up oh
well i can't sleep but you can't sleep
in my house but you can sleep upstairs
he puts me in this liquor room with the
smell of mice and rats and
you know and then he started telling me
things that
i really didn't need to know at that age
like like things about my mother and
drugs and how my mother got high when i
was inside of her and just [ __ ] that you
don't tell somebody and i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about you know
right
and telling me that i would never amount
to anything because of the bloodline i
came from and
i'm like this is [ __ ] cool
i don't our hispanic parents a little
bit more straight i don't know if it's
straightforward or cruel than like white
parents are or not i don't want to say
white but that world was a little bit
more they were more realistic i've
noticed it like it's not that they're
mean that i mean that sounds terrible
but it's like they don't pull punches
like white parents would never say some
of the stuff i've seen
so he told i didn't know this until
after i made up with him yeah because
his kids told me the story like when you
came to town that time
he called the house he wasn't living
without us then but he kept calling the
house telling us not to answer the phone
have you called
[ __ ] you know like this is my uncle this
is my blood you know if i started
thinking about this
i apologize to him 25 years later for my
behavior
but he's never take me aside and say hey
man
i was on the line that weekend too by
the things i said to you you know you
wouldn't amount to nothing that i mean
when i got on that plane after we drew
guns on each other
and i got on that [ __ ] plane to
jersey
you know once the smoke cleared i got
furiously
i had i i realized what it had done to
me
i was furiously i think on one of the
testicle testaments i talk about how i
used to call him from prison yeah and
hang on i'm gonna kill him
and hang up on it
i mean this was going back
till [ __ ] i came out here i was kind
of scared and then i looked them up once
when i first moved him with terry terry
had a yellow pages and i looked up the
bar
and i saw it was open i called him from
terry's phone
and the number had a machine to it so i
knew he still had the bar
and i was talking to marilyn martinez
one day like oh man where's vermont
and she goes it's right there in
hollywood why and i go my uncle has a
bar
at this number and she goes hold on now
has david
and david her husband was black you know
he's from crenshaw and she goes yeah
yeah there's a bar down there
a mexican bar i'd still go that's my
uncle and i remember going you know what
if i fail here
on the way out of town i'm gonna go and
hit him with a [ __ ] two by four hit
him and i was dead seriously i was
pissed
butly you get older
you know and you listen to people and
people always say to forgive
and it's like i forgive but i never
forgot i never really forgot him and
sometimes i meet with him and i want to
bring it up like no what the [ __ ] were
you thinking
you know at that time he had cheated on
his wife
with some chick
and then cheated on that chick with
another chick and gotten her pregnant
the third chip the third chicken the
kids around today
and the poor kid you know because of his
behavior the poor kid you could see the
kids [ __ ] up too because
the mother didn't want the mother
dropped him off one day and said i don't
want this [ __ ] kid oh no you know
because it was like she was a joke to
the lover
if you're not gonna be with me i don't
want this [ __ ] kid i want the kid if
we're gonna be together type deal can
you imagine that no
so that's the hell he lives in you know
and uh
i explained to my wife yesterday my wife
told me she goes you know what i i
didn't really
understand the severity of what he had
done to you until yesterday it was it
was horridly
hard like how i went home
after three days and then i tried to
lash out yeah i tried to lash out and
rob him and put a take a gun out on him
because
i couldn't take what he was saying to me
anymore what if he said it now like what
if he had said it at this age would it
have affected you as much
no because i'm confident who i am i
already know who the [ __ ] i am at that
age my dad had died at three my mom had
died at 16.
i had an idea i i wasn't [ __ ] stupid
you know what i'm saying right but he
said things i'm about working and he's
like so what do you want to be a
bartender he goes that's as far as
you'll ever get he goes if you're lucky
you you might make a good bartender
i can't see you doing anything else i
said well you know i might want to go to
school and be a lawyer because you can't
be a lawyer when you're a criminal
it's not in your blood type i mean he
just was saying
and at first i i was like was like that
girl that's insecure that talks to a
pimp and a pimp tells her and i was like
this guy is [ __ ] crazy he's not
he doesn't know anything about me
i just i'm on coke and i i had a bad run
a life and i'm gonna get this you know
when i left there and the whole point of
getting
i think in 84 the whole point of getting
out of that [ __ ] rocket ship was to
get my [ __ ] together go put a bullet in
his [ __ ] head
that was the plan the whole time but
then over the do you think any of it is
he was just trying to motivate you like
did anything no no no no there's no way
there's a way to motivate people there's
a way to talk to somebody with love
there's a way to talk to somebody [ __ ]
up and then reel him back with love
he just talked to me [ __ ] up there was
no love there was nothing you know
sometimes your dad would go lead you got
to do this you know and you feel bad and
he goes i'm telling you this i'm your
dad i love you
and on the way to the car you go you
know what i can't because he's talking
to me from the heart this guy said
nothing from the heart the only thing he
threw at me from the heart was hate
and this anger and this you know
resentment and then the other thing
there was more that story my mother had
given him money
this is what really shocked me
because i was [ __ ] up on drugs it was
five years later but my mother had given
him a ton of money before she died
i don't know what the terms were or
whatever
so i thought when i would come out and
he'd go hey man your mom gave me money
before she died she gave me twenty
thousand he's five
get your life together i wouldn't have
complained lee i wouldn't have said
anything
he didn't even make that effort you know
so it was just uh
it's just a [ __ ] up time i'm gonna you
know i gotta talk about revenge
i love revenge
i i've always loved when ari first
called me with the [ __ ] story
i thought about when i was a kid one
night this buddy of mine got hit
and uh the guy was a lot older than him
we were probably 16
17
and this guy was in his 20s i remember
him from being like a freshman in high
school he was a lot older than i was and
he was always a [ __ ] but he dated
a friend
like a girl that i knew
and she was young like she was like a
sophomore and he was like a sophomore in
college probably you know we were
probably juniors in high school and this
guy hit a friend of mine and i go bro it
would be my honor let's get back at this
guy
regardless of the whatever comes back
from it right and we uh set up this
thing and the guy came out we hit him
with a wiffle ball bat with rocks in it
oh we got a ruffle ball bat we cut it we
put rocks in and then you put a big rock
at the end so the rocks don't come out
you throw a little dirt in that
[ __ ] you have no idea how hard a
whiffer ball bat hurts when it's at the
rocks it would probably hurt empty
it burns empty yeah it burns empty you
get hit with a wiffle ball about 15
times in the neck or somewhere the
skin's exposed i just imagine on the
back like
but with rocks in it oh my god
and that was my favorite revenge story
i've always i've always day-dreamed
about revenge i i don't think i ever the
only thing i ever did was this freaking
[ __ ] in high school was pushing me
around he was younger than i was but he
was bigger because i was small
and one day he was messing with me in
the gym locker room i don't remember
exactly what he was doing but i had
enough i was like i think i was like a
junior or a senior and i just slammed
him against some lockers and we we
started
it was like the only real fight i've
ever been in we don't think any punches
were even thrown i just remember
slamming his head against some lockers
and i got suspended for a day but i was
so my mom wasn't even mad
i was so happy it was the only time i
ever did it you stuck up for yourself
it's weird that people think revenge is
revenge is like for me revenge isn't
just about that it's like when like
somebody'll go hey man
[ __ ] uh
you know somebody will say to me you
know what uh you should make me your
partner i don't really think lee's a
good partner for you and i go okay
and then the podcaster won an award
yeah i'll see that person go come here
for a second that's revenge to me yeah
that was always my big revenge i feel
that way now for like people who are
mean to me in high school and i i go on
facebook and they're they're still
working at the high school john
which is fine but a little bit i feel
like yeah take that [ __ ] yeah like a
couple of them have hit me up like they
come out to l.a and like we should hang
out i'm like we were never friends in
high school
where am i going to drive all the way to
los feliz to see you now
and [ __ ] no parking right
you know revenge like for me with my
ex-wife i really want
but i knew that
if i stuck around and did well
that would hurt her more
you know she wanted me to either end up
dead disappear or go to prison
because that would never have contact
right with them again
but i kept that and for me that was my
revenge it was succeeding at something
so revenge is also something like that
you know yeah somebody fires you and
says you're [ __ ] an idiot really
i'm gonna go over to your competitor and
watch what i do over there
and after about two years you eat that
[ __ ] lunch you just call them
everything how you like me now [ __ ] and
hang up or breathe heavy you go
and hang up whatever the [ __ ] you do you
know
i mean that's that was always revenge
for me in a way so
when he called me and told me about the
topic my dick got hard it was perfect
for me yeah but it's just uh
it's kind of weird how
you're supposed to like family and
there's some people like parents unless
they do something terrible i'm always
going to be there for my parents
but other than that
you're simply like people make you feel
bad if you if you don't
love them or don't have a good
relationship with them which in reality
it's just you got you got stuck with
them
and hopefully you have a good
relationship but you don't have to
i get it i i get one thing in life that
you're not gonna get along with
everybody
okay you can't you can't life's not that
easy i wish everybody i bumped into
we shook hands and flowers popped up and
white birds came out that's what you
want but unfortunately some people like
some people's personalities some people
you know like how somebody looks some
people don't like how somebody sounds
you know i'm guilty of it also i mean
we're all guilty of it
and we're allowed to you know you can't
like everything you know
and sometimes two brothers aren't going
to get along right sometimes a sibling
and a
a sister and a brother i get along for
certain reasons you know
when i see it
you know for me it was always my dream
to have a brother
so for my world i don't understand
you're not getting along with your
brother and now it's sort of gotten to
the point where
we just don't not you i'm not we know
you oh no but yeah but just for i don't
i haven't talked to my brother in months
oh he called a few weeks ago we talked
for like 10 seconds but uh
we we used to i used to hate them like
when i lived with them i hated them
but now it's just we were in different
places
um
but do you think part of it might have
to do like i met you
when you hadn't been a criminal for
years
do you think part of it is
your cousins and your uncle just
remember back then and that's why
they're not looking at how you are now
no no no because we got a long grade i
get along great with my
my my uncle has two children and one
legitimate child i get along with the
kids all three of them i've gotten along
in fact the tightest woman i'm with is
marta
she just came to my movie shoot and see
me valerie
yeah i'm real tight with it okay i just
she just took what i said wrong i said
it as a get it together
she took it as a wrong thing like you
know if i came to your house lee and
we were all in the kitchen eating your
mom your dad family cousins and you're
in the living room watching a football
game i'm gonna look at you and go dog
are you [ __ ] serious yeah your
parents are in the other room come on
[ __ ] the score we'll get it later tape
it who cares you know that's it if you
get insulted by that
i you know i can't be uh
i think there was more going on okay and
i didn't know that when i said that to
her and i tried to apologize later but
she walked away from me so
like i said i called her the other day
after she wished my daughter a happy
birthday dog i cover the
i cover the bases
you know i'm very fortunate you know i
said it a thousand times god took my
parents
but he showed me the gift of friendship
and
i don't believe you have to have a
million friends if you do more power to
you
i believe that you could take over the
world i could take over the world with
you
tom brady and a rabbi with a big black
dick i'm saying
a black rabbi or a white rabbi with a
black dick i could take over the world i
could take over the world
in my mind and i can't but you guys know
what i'm coming from yeah
with a support system with your good
friends that's all you [ __ ] need
you know you want to have 50 people at
your birthday party so be it 15 of them
are laughing at you
you know you really got six or seven
[ __ ] in your corner your life's
mission is to pluck those six out and to
move forward like [ __ ] you know like
[ __ ] a soldier that's what you do
if you want to have 50 [ __ ] people so
be it and have 50 [ __ ] people jesus
had 12 and one [ __ ] turn
what makes you [ __ ] think that you're
better than [ __ ] jesus right okay
because people are going to be your
friends they're not going to be happy
with your accomplishments maybe what
you're not accomplishing this kind of
goes back to the comedy central thing i
would say when you were talking about it
when i was younger i wanted everyone to
like me and i still everyone watched
people liked them
but it took me a while not to
force myself into people who don't want
me there
so like did any did you try to get in
the comment section and then like you
realize like i'm no you don't want me
there i know i know you you know you
know how people
treat you how people react to you you
know when somebody wants you around
you know i always get calls from them
for a free showcase in santa monica on a
sale tuesday at 7 you know
what's wrong with melrose what's wrong
with you know
and my feelings don't get hurt it just
makes a guy like me want to work a
little harder
you know when an avenue shuts on you so
many people come out here and they go i
can't wait to get into the store then
they get up there mitzi don't like them
you could take that two ways you could
take that as i'm done
or you could take that with nobody's
gonna like everybody jamie masada's
gonna like me and i'm going to take what
jamie masada offers me and make the best
of what i can make of it if it's one
spot a week that's what i'll do oh [ __ ]
mitzi don't like me but the store likes
me the improv likes me right guy at the
improv thinks i'm quirky and he gives me
tuesdays and thursdays
that's a start
small commitments become big commitments
so
not everybody's going to dig you me you
don't know and work when you had these
jobs you were working at you liked
everybody in the [ __ ] office no other
five people how many did you really like
how many people would you invite to your
home to watch a new england game to see
you in your natural habitat
probably none okay to be honest yeah
yeah no no you have acquaintances
everybody has acquaintances what i'm
talking about is four [ __ ] that
i could call like i call you at six in
the morning sometime
and i go hey dawg i'm thinking of doing
this so do we do i call you the [ __ ]
round with you
the interview no i call you
to tell you i love you i got your back
to do something with yourself in the
morning i always beat you up in the
morning get up yeah the [ __ ] you doing i
mean get the [ __ ] up go get up go see
the sunlight those are your friends
those are your friends you see how
they're doing with those four people
when my world goes aside right now every
once in a while you know what i call
loops
i've known lube since i was 16 is the
first guy i would blow it
because no matter what's going on in my
life loser always make me giggle a
little bit even if he just stunned his
one time
i'm hollering what are you doing
i'm over here watching the football game
boom i'm dying to laughter because it
hasn't changed he hasn't changed
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about brad pitt
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about the golden
globes which i put on last night for 10
minutes oh i didn't even put it on let
me tell you something my wife was
watching me and i was in between writing
and [ __ ] around
and i went outside to smoke pot on the
way and i looked at this korean or
whatever this asian chicken away that's
margaret cho
so uh whatever and the other chick had
margaret show up on stage
doing little stuck like acting like the
korean guy dressed in the korean
communist suit oh no and margaret i tell
you man she was pretty good one time
really i watched one i watched three
minutes of it just to see where they
were going i'm like who's this this
market joe i'm a margaret joe fan
says margaret [ __ ] joe
and all of a sudden amy polo walks away
and the other girl
and she walks the opposite direction by
walking like hitler yeah and the
performers were coming right out she was
pretty [ __ ] good you know
margaret cho came out here and got the
shaft you know like they put her greg
geraldo and tom rhodes on tv after tim
out that's a lot of people don't
remember i'm old enough i remember this
that was my developing years watching
greg gerald go on i think it was common
law
and then they canceled uh tom rhodes
greg geraldo and they cancelled uh
margaret cho right i don't know if
margaret shows shows lasted i don't
remember so don't quote me on this and
you know what what do you do
when your show gets canceled what do you
do do you [ __ ] pack your bags and go
home
no you're still a stand-up you lost
nothing you took a chance
you know it's up to you whether or not
you continue as an actor
or act part-time a [ __ ] dustander and
margaret cho kept writing and kept
developing and kept [ __ ] around and
kept her fan base alive and margaret cho
sell some [ __ ] tickets dog still yeah
[ __ ] yeah 2 000 gay people with tattoos
will show up at her shows yelling and
screaming smoking reefer i opened for
her years ago in dallas and i had a
[ __ ] phenomenal time
it was mind-boggling the people that
come out to see her transgenders
transvestites
people with wigs on and they're all
[ __ ] dynamite everybody's got poppers
and uh she gets a lot of like just you
know
i don't know what they call those people
gentiles like in motion i guess gentiles
in motion i like that
gin gym
gentiles and motion that's a new [ __ ]
watch that'll be big in about two years
with gentiles in motion
but she was [ __ ] rocking
and i saw how she acted afterward and i
was very i've always been a fan of hers
really but after i worked with her i
really got do you see listen man it's
not a minority lab she has
it's what she's doing right what she's
doing how much how much
respect do you have for other comedians
like even because i would never think
you'd like margaret show not not dislike
her but i wouldn't think she'd be your
speed
i know who's bringing the funk and i
know who's faking it because for years i
did it
you're following me not as a comic but
as a human being
so i know who's bringing the funk and i
know who's faking it
you know
20 years from now you just watch the
comic on club mtv
vh1 when they had stand up you watched
them on uh
whatever evening at the improv was on
and you watched them on hbo
and that's it you knew nothing about the
comic
you liked them there was maybe i don't
know how many comedy clubs he came to
your town you went down there some of
them came out and spoke to you some of
them didn't
now it's about the complete package but
for me
it's always been about the complete
package
you don't know how many times when i
started the fans of comic i was a fan of
a lot of comics
until i got to meet them
and it's like anything else you know
it's like anything else in life what you
see behind the curtain
so it's a natural
reaction how many comments do i have
respect for
first off i have respect for people like
bill burr who was also on a big time
show and got cancelled
because it's not getting canceled it's
what you do with getting cancelled
you're gonna have a thousand road bumps
in any [ __ ] career
whether it's painting or fruit stand or
fishing it's gonna be [ __ ]
last night i'm trying to write this book
and i'm like this is the most
frustrating [ __ ] thing
i've ever done this and [ __ ] jiu
jitsu are just mind-boggling how [ __ ]
frustrating they are but
stand-up was probably really frustrating
for me and i i know it was for a fact
because i know
i remember wanting to
get forward and not
uh joe perez you know joe perez's
the the young comic out here yeah he's
great i love joe perez and joe perez the
young guy i listened to the podcast
and he got interested in comedy and i
guess he's from long beach
but his father is in the valley and he
heard us and he came to visit his father
and he saw the haha
and he saw all the places that we speak
about and he came up here and he uh
moved up here and he signed up for
college at valley college and he's
taking classes and he goes to the haha
and he does the open mic and he does all
the right things
but he's stuck
he's [ __ ] stuck
he wrote me an email
do i want to see him go
not really
okay like leave like leave or go back to
long beach because he misses his family
you know over here he's struggling he'd
go to long beach and and you know sleep
in his own bed and probably have a job
and have a car and have rides to
different places i don't know i don't
know he had a car that night mm-hmm in
the in the la and at the ice house right
new years right i think so i love joe
the other problem with joe is i haven't
had much time to spend with him
as a comic i don't go out that much the
family the podcast
this is toughly this is a tough jiggle
trying to write trying to stay healthy
just all these little [ __ ] things it
gets tough for you you know right and i
haven't but when i see him he's a great
kid he's he's he's warm he's receptive
we've had some edibles together with him
he's very nice yeah i need another star
not another one no all right you don't
want to start the month it's [ __ ]
monday yeah uh
so i wrote back in the email that you
know
i understand but he didn't fail
he came out here he looked and now he
knows what he has to do and long beach
isn't far away no yeah and if there's
open mics everywhere or you create open
mics
i can't get an email from iowa going i
want to be a comic but there's no open
mice well you know what everybody likes
money [ __ ] oh
get up get a [ __ ] piece of paper
write out a plan for your open mic write
out what you're going to charge and go
to a bar and go we want to charge three
dollars on a wednesday night
we'll get 10 people here in the
beginning but i want to do it every
wednesday
from 8 to 10 and after a year it'll grow
and guess what else will happen
i'll grow as a comedian you know i'll
grow as a theater artist so i'll grow is
whatever even if i just go up there and
do [ __ ] shakespeare you know one
scene from shakespeare by myself
whatever
but it must be even though you haven't
got to hang out with joe it's kind of
like
as a comedian you've been there
you you can relate to when you can talk
about certain things listen if you write
to me and you tell me you install
linoleum yeah
and you're stuck in your life i don't
know what to tell you maybe you should
tell italian [ __ ] i know about little
things about linoleum
but if you come to me and you look me in
the eye you talk to me about comedy i
know exactly where you're at because i
can tell from your feel
from your voice from the pain when
you're talking to me we all have that
pain but it lessens you know we're all
trying to kill that pain but it lessens
the better you get at this or the more
you would achieve your goals or the
easier life becomes the pain goes down
he's 20 19 20.
he can move to [ __ ] long beach and do
comedy in front of a mirror
for five years and come back here when
he's 25 and still be a killer yeah do
you follow me yeah they are so what this
is a little hard for him now and it's
going to be hard listen man but a story
that a lot of people don't know is i
went to new york in 1994 as a comic
from boulder
when i went to new york
to it was for various reasons it was for
one to give my relationship space number
two i had a friend who was gonna help me
but number three was the purpose of
getting better at stand up
you know how much effort i put into it
not too much i put in
just enough for joey diaz at the time
and guess what happened lee i failed but
i didn't fail
i got to understand what i had to do to
take it to the next level now i had a
decision to make
now i had a decision to make you know uh
somebody told me that child went to
college and and didn't like
it was too hard for them and i had had a
conversation with this parent years ago
and said don't send him to college
whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do make
him go down there a few days a week and
see what these [ __ ] are really
doing before he signs up for this right
he never did that so he spent all this
money in this [ __ ] college got him
out there and the kid came home
because it was too rough for me to know
this is what he wanted to do you know
that kid feels like [ __ ] now their
parents feel like [ __ ] [ __ ] now but
he didn't fail
he came home he had a rose beef sandwich
and you're gonna set a plan it's just
like goals or writing a plan you got
your ass kicked for what
you're gonna get your ass kicked every
[ __ ] day of your normal
life [ __ ] you up some way or another
you drive over a [ __ ]
bottle you get a flat tire what are you
gonna do
you're gonna tap on no you get the
[ __ ] tire fixed and you go to work
and tell him to go [ __ ] himself where's
tony bennett here it's a beautiful day
to be alive
monday january 12th if you didn't
achieve your goal last week you'll
achieve it let this week last week i
wrote down i was going to two jiu jitsu
monday i went to 10th planet wednesday i
went to [ __ ] hegan if you don't write
it ain't gonna happen
oh [ __ ]
how you feeling buddy i'm pretty [ __ ]
up are you [ __ ] up you ready for
another start that no a joint and one
star is good one little joint
sure
what's up buddy
that's the beauty of it
you were [ __ ] up on saturday but and
then you were sick but you still went
outside i was surprised like i was like
not nothing like you could you always
talk to people but you were standing in
the rain and like you had a cold
listen bro
what are you gonna do
these people come from australia
they come from [ __ ] lancaster they
come from all over they gotta have a few
drinks and drive home with dui alerts
everywhere i gotta give them a hug i
gotta take a picture
you know if they're willing to take a
picture with a guy that's [ __ ]
leaking from his nose
you gotta give him a [ __ ] hug right
they made the effort
they made the effort they drove down
it's time for another stop are you
really popping another storm [ __ ] yeah
it's monday it's january 12th
i got goals i gotta write today i don't
know if i'm gonna work out because it's
shittier i'm still gonna give my lungs
another break i don't have much today
brother maybe we go get a steak time
greg and lynn gave us that [ __ ] thing
from ruth chris i want to thank him love
again
oh my god oh my god what that's a
vitamin for uncle joey i just popped a
vitamin some people papa one of them
that's my [ __ ] one event except
there's not one in there it's one every
30 minutes what are you gonna do you
know what i'm saying you gotta get to
the goal regardless of what your goal is
it's monday what did you do paula was
sofa because she gave me one on saturday
and she just kept looking at me she's
like are you high yet because she's
never done it so she was like kind of
interested she's like you high yet and
she started giggling a little bit i said
no not yet and then like
i think you were going off
about something crazy at the show and i
just started dying and she started
looking at me and she just she was like
always put you into the guy yeah yeah
because you start giggling my wife
always knows when i'm [ __ ] giggling
[ __ ] up uh there was a cat fight this
morning
and i go out there and fidel standing
there in the middle of it so he's back
okay people keep asking me thank you for
all the fidel warm wishes out there he's
doing great man he's a good cat and i'm
happy i still haven't got the [ __ ]
bill from the vet i don't know what's
going on in the middle do you have pet
insurance
i got every type of insurance when it
comes to those [ __ ] cats you need a
dog those [ __ ] cats
you just take them but i got you know
what i got a pretty affordable vet
i got a good guy in studio city takes
good care of me v
v mac or something like that that's your
jiu jitsu please no vmac or something i
think it is i don't know they were debit
they were really good to my wife and
they were good to me and they
they like fidel you know i have a couple
and i have a lady jill
who uh works at a pet place over here
and i go over there and see her from
vitamins and stuff i have a
few people they know you know i take
care of their cats and [ __ ] on the block
you know jill is down the corner from me
but she's got biggie
that's her in her house biggie lives
outside and uh in
the the smokey he's like a great cat his
friend yeah his goomba and they're
always by my house chilling and [ __ ] so
she's like thank you for
and it's i i love having an animal
community
i love millie i love the the rottweiler
up the corner
the black guy with the pitbull that
wouldn't put him on the leash move to
somebody gave him a ticket something
happened with him because i don't see
him anymore okay he was a big scumbag
but besides that we still have a lot of
nice people in the neighborhood
there's a tall blonde with a german
shepherd that he's [ __ ] beautiful
she's beautiful but you want to see the
dog oh really that's crazy like she's
tall lanky really sweet but you see the
dog and he jumps on you he always
nibbles on your hands and [ __ ] a little
bit i love him i love him so i'm sorry i
get emotional
i'm happy that cat's good uh
as we've been talking about i went to
see a doctor last week uh
i have a really good cardiologist
whatever the heart doctor is he's a
friend i i got to i didn't go to him
because i had a bad heart i wanted him
because it was a bad ekg reading
and we ended up becoming friends
and we spoke you know we speak once a
month and he talks about my weight and
he talks to me about new breakthroughs
he's a good guy dr solomony and he once
about three years maybe four years ago
he referred
a gastric bypass to me and i told him he
was crazy and he he offered to give me a
cost you know and
he was just really nice to me and i said
you know if you're willing to do that i
have to work out on my end so i went to
weight watchers i lost 100 pounds and
we've always kept in touch i go see him
twice a year and he does my blood
pressure but the last two times he's
been really concerned
with my blood pressure he's mentioned it
again he's like you should go but i
thought about it i went to new york and
i bumped into lisa lampanelli
and she told me after again buffini died
that it was big that a lot of people at
50 were doing it because you just
you know you just don't
it's just virtually impossible how hard
is it to lose weight when you're at your
age right now
i do it i do it but i don't do it at the
rate i want to do it i see you sometimes
and you're like i can't believe i'm
stuck here
i'm in the same boat sometimes i like it
was dropping a lot easier with the
weight watchers now i'm doing more
and it seems like it's not coming off
you know and i've been doing in my
fitness which i love i think it's
[ __ ] great you know it's great but
it's and we were talking about it
earlier
you could have 23 great hours
but
anything after 9 or 10 o'clock
it's never you're not gonna lose it i
gotta be honest with you guys thursday i
did a tremendous kettlebell session
on friday it was shitty out friday i
didn't have to do anything friday night
it was shittier
it was like five o'clock it was cloudy i
went over there
i must have did ten sets of swings
i was breathing right i had two great
workouts last week you know but the
kettlebell i had two weight workouts
that were great i had a barbell workout
when i rode the bike on sunday monday i
went to jiu-jitsu with tuesday i took
off
wednesday i went to jiu jitsu with higan
and friday i did the kettlebells i was
sore thursday from the jiu jitsu on
wednesday
and friday did the kettlebells i had to
assembly i didn't eat an edible fry
and just from pushing that metal around
i was so [ __ ] hungry
i was so [ __ ] hungry
so i did one protein shake 30 grams of
protein 300 calories
boom about an hour away like i got to do
it again i'm [ __ ] starving i did it
again
boom i ate an apple
two organic apples
a banana
and then there was salami and cheese
that [ __ ] went down like a
submarine
and you have this willpower and you try
and that was it like it's not like i'm
eating chips and eating ice cream
nothing like that the other night when i
dropped you off with paul i went to
7-eleven
and i got a protein bar a no sugar
protein bar you know i really wanted to
stop at that diner and get a
cheeseburger and a piece of apple pie
with you guys i really really wanted to
go i was just as high as the next guy
but i try but when you try like that and
you're still just losing a pound a week
it just gets discouraging right
you say what the [ __ ] and then so if i'm
going to be this weight anyway you just
went anyway but i don't throw it like
that no i'm really good like that i'll
say you know what i'll just be patient
because i know i'm doing the right thing
if i'm drinking a lot of water i'm
drinking green tea it's not like i'm
drinking any soda at all
you know yeah what did i have when i
drank soda i had something that you got
to have with soda i forget what the [ __ ]
it was but and then yeah dad dug the
girl gave me a glass of coke and i gotta
tell you it tasted pretty [ __ ] good
yeah i felt bad she goes it's coke
what am i gonna say give me diet coke
and now what are you gonna do with this
one i just drank it was six or seven
ounces
wasn't bad but besides i'm drinking
green tea and more [ __ ] those gallons
of water go at my house those [ __ ]
right they go i think you'll notice if
you do this because it you said it takes
your stomach down to like two ounces i
don't even know what it is now it has to
be like 10. it has to be
a [ __ ] tuba i think you'll realize
when you can only eat that much how much
you were eating because that's the thing
that with my fitness pal i didn't you
don't think you're eating that much and
then the more you put in like oh [ __ ]
just that little bit was 800 calories or
so maybe
who knows i mean i hope it works but
well you know i went i talked to him
uh i think your stomach goes from a
liter to two ounces
it's not you know at first i for the
last three or four years a dear friend
of mine uh henzo blake gracie black belt
john rallo has a friend that had it
and his friend had great success with it
and he kept calling me and going joy
you're killing yourself because he's
older he's 50 he was 50 when he did it
also
i'm like come on you could do it by
going to the gym he goes bro i go every
day ronald was like dog this guy works
harder than anybody i know
and uh
he's healthy now what the breaking point
for me was
when i went to this doctor last monday i
got to be honest with you i did not want
to go
i did everything i could not to go to
this meeting last monday at two o'clock
i even called him and said i'm running
late i'm working at fox studios and
they're like
oh no i was like damn so i got then it
was an orientation class and
you sit there and describe the procedure
to you what's going to happen what to
expect and i'll tell you man
the procedure sounds easy
it's not the procedure it's leading up
to it and afterwards it's hard work
first of all two weeks of just a liquid
[ __ ] diet
that's murder
right that's murder i think a month
before i gotta go on a liquid diet but
two weeks before that oh no no sugar no
ice cream you know milkshake without ice
cream is like sucking a dick and nothing
coming out it's like sucking a dry [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying where's the
payoff where's the [ __ ] payoff no
squirt no not gonna dry [ __ ] that's
terrible what the [ __ ] are you gonna do
a milkshake with water and powder
and
you know that don't fly with me but i
called my buddy ralph of fuso who had it
done and he oh he had it done yeah rob
finally tapped out all that's who really
got me thinking about it
joan had it her daughter had a kelly at
35
and then once ralph had like around
break it down to me he goes i couldn't
shake off the weight plus my blood
pressure was too high for a long time
now when i got locked up in prison i was
possibly the best shape of my life i
didn't have a car
i rode a bike everywhere in boulder in
high altitude
i was part of a master swimming program
i had a boxing regiment that i worked
out with and i lifted weights
i was always doing something i would
worked at hearts it hurts rent a car
which meant i was always moving my my
you know i was in tip-top [ __ ] shape
my diet was great you know i had a the
guy that the master swimming guy put me
on protein shakes and i was eating eggs
and i wasn't touching potatoes and i was
a young kid
and i went to prison and the first and
they flagged me was at the diagnostic
center for my high blood pressure
feeling like your blood pressure's off
the charts you're 27 years old
did you know about this and i'm like no
i had a [ __ ] idea i'm cuban my
asshole's always on fire i mean
you know i'm always on overdrive in my
mind so i had a [ __ ] idea
that maybe my blood pressure's high
and then they put me on medication and
i've been doing this since i was 27
years old wow so if i 27 in tip-top
shape my blood pressure was high it's
[ __ ] aster every time i walk into a
doctor's office they take my blood
pressure and they read me the numbers
and my head [ __ ] falls off then i
rest for 10 minutes there and then it
goes down gradually but still not
tremendous at this point in my life i'm
like three or four uh medications for
blood pressure i think oh wow yeah and
and then last monday when i went to this
fat man doctor you have to do this thing
you have to watch every i was there for
a few hours three or four hours so i
don't even know
because
you weren't heavy before you went to
prison yeah so
the does is it just all mostly genetic
and then way just makes it worse because
i
i think the blood pressure thing was
genetic
maybe
yes it was from my mother's side maybe
my my uncle was okay with it
but the uh the weight i don't know where
i got it from you know my mother had a
lot of movement also she moved also i
didn't get this way from
you know you know my mother wasn't lazy
my mother [ __ ] moved in the daytime
so
she put weight on after her bar closed
not hundreds of pounds
you know i did a dramatic weight gain oh
my godly it was
and it was in a short period of time i
went from a to z
you know i went from 260 to 350
to 400 like there was no in-betweens it
felt like
every time i looked at the scale i was
putting 20 pounds on you know
so at this point
i felt really guilty i i couldn't
believe i was even considering the
surgery
then i had mercy
you know it's gonna take me two years to
lose this [ __ ] weight you know what
guys you see me on stage i'm gonna
stroke out
you know i'm on stage doing a lot better
because my heart's into it more there's
no more blockage there's no cocaine
i'm talking about what i believe in it's
not like i'm up there trying to be funny
for comedy central or some agency i'm
talking what's in my heart
so it makes it easy to come across but
to also sell that you got to have that
little anger on me that little engine
running cost you it cost me you know
right
so uh yeah i'm gonna have the gastric
done going for the
uh psychological evaluation
on uh wednesday mm-hmm i'm going to
support group wednesday night this week
and the next week the 21st yeah and then
hopefully by then i'll get my uh
insurance will say yes
and i'll uh
get a surgery date that's awesome it's
kind of like what you're talking about
earlier like
you looked at it like a failure kind of
when you thought about doing the surgery
but it's not but you work you're working
out more than ever you're eating
healthier
it's just in the next step it's you
listen man i look at mercy and i know
what it is to grow up without a dad
you know i could sit here when i write
these little books and these little
memoirs and my pages
you know i put a lot of it on my mother
but it really wasn't my mother that's
what my [ __ ] up started with
my dad didn't come home
you know my mother used to tell me when
you were a little kid for years every
time the door would open
you look at the door to see if it was
your father that just thinking of that
thought for mercy
pains me because i know how tight her
and i are already at this age you know
we're getting really tight
you know i was uh
thinking about
the triads did i tell you about this
yeah triads like the asian gangs asian
gangs
were where the mafia concept came from
the italians didn't create the mafia the
chinese did it's a it's a chinese
concept
but the guys
the early guys that started the the
concept
they figured out that they used their
daughters as bodyguards and confidants
did you know that they use their
daughters because your daughter is your
[ __ ] best friend in the world
to have a daughter is a certain [ __ ]
power that you don't see
uh
i can't see it when i see movies about a
a girl getting raped i can't imagine how
a father must feel it's like he got
raped you know
and that's at every [ __ ] level with
your kids but a daughter
father bond is very strong in some
cultures it's even stronger you know it
started getting to the point where even
the sicilians started using their
daughters as bodyguards and confidants
because all the men were getting shot
and getting taken to [ __ ] jail
you know a woman
a a
a girl a a daughter is not gonna let her
dad do time and vice versa
right you know it's it's a really weird
thing so and i already see the bond
building
i understand that what happens to women
when they grow up without a dad or
they have beef with their dad it's tough
right now how cool was it on her
birthday like i saw the picture with the
carvel cake
god damn it was just the carvel cake was
[ __ ] delicious
delicious
she loved it she loved it
i loved it listen mercy she was too but
she didn't know the [ __ ] planet she
was on that day
she didn't know she just i took her to
kids space
a little place up in pasadena you pay 11
bucks
and you let them [ __ ] loosen there
and she ran and she picked up
there's things to build
there's all this like scientist type
[ __ ] where you put a ball in the
catapult and pull it down the ball
shoots out you're having more fun than
she is yeah then it rolls to the side
there's another thing where you pull
ropes
she there was one place where you built
[ __ ] and there was balls on the floor
all she kept doing was pick up the balls
and hide them and then she'd go to get
more a little kid would see her balls
take him and then she'd go what the [ __ ]
are my boys at him again and i sat there
for hours and wants to do that then you
go inside and there's like an
underground tunnel and
you know spiders and [ __ ] uh
beehives and [ __ ] she didn't give a [ __ ]
about none of that all she gave a [ __ ]
was about running
and uh two o'clock we had some lunch
that nice lunch up there had tuna salad
yeah with no bread you know it was nice
lunch
i thought it was gonna be dog [ __ ] but
it was delicious
and then we just went home and relaxed
when she took a nap when she woke up
we each had a piece of a caramel cake
and we sang a happy birthday and that
was it she still didn't know what planet
she was on once she ate the sugar from
the caravel cake she was really [ __ ]
up
but it was a great day it was a great
day for the house you know uh
like i said my wife is in another
[ __ ] planet right now lee yeah so as
long as she's [ __ ] happy i don't give
a [ __ ] let's crack the whacking you know
what i'm saying right
what does she think about you doing the
surgery because she she met you when you
were 400. well i well she met me when i
was about three
tens oh okay maybe 280
to 80. really and then you went up to
four hours yeah she started frying food
and [ __ ]
you know when i first met terry those
first that first two years we hate jack
yeah
beans and [ __ ] pork chops and
desserts and pineapple upside down cake
and that was just at the house never
mind what i eat when i leave you know
when you go to county at the comedy
store you see where you're close to
you're close to the pink taco you're
close to pinches tacos
you're close to the have you ever been
to the
to the standard and gotten the blue
cheeseburger yeah i understand
you don't know what you're missing son
they got that [ __ ] thing carnies and
they saw hot dogs and cheeseburgers and
chili dogs there so when you first moved
to the store you just eat around the
store
yeah
no no no no no [ __ ] planet no no
i'm i'm always up for late night food
yeah [ __ ] yeah i just don't understand
eating like there's no place to really
get a good was that place open that
night 24 7. no we went to the subway i
know you went the [ __ ] subway it's
probably open but it was open when we
drove by i thought the diner probably i
don't know
how
it said open but i didn't see anybody in
there sometimes they're old they forgot
to turn the open sign off they thought
it pulled in there and they were closed
i'm [ __ ] pissed off you know but no i
think i'm gonna do the gastric sleeve
and i've got a little support group yeah
kelly davidson i've got
uh ralph a fuso i've got my other buddy
who had it martin in florida i got about
four friends that had it so i called
them all up i asked them what they
thought
i called every doctor i deal with
radicchi the [ __ ]
psychoanalyst that took the hypnotize me
so i could breathe better i called my
knee doctor i called
the family dr wyatt discussed it with he
gave me the recommendation what about dr
amy i talked to doctor henry about it
because dr amy shares an office with a
guy who does lap bands uh-huh
so she knows more a little bit about it
so i called her first
so i talked to everybody and everybody
was conclusive man that this is uh
i talked to joe joe sent a
an email to one of his doctor buddies
and she sent us an email together she
cc'd it and it was very interesting
you know the only downfall is
deficiencies and vitamins
i
think
because you can't eat as much
and yeah i don't think you put the pills
in you like the vitamin pills at first
okay so i'll lose my hair
really i'll lose a little bit of hair
until my protein and everything comes
back up
you know there's deficiencies in b12 you
have deficiencies in vitamin d but
the other side is that is my blood
pressure my it's uh
you know all that stuff affects
everything the weight affects the joints
i like exercising
i like sweating i like going down and
feeling like a [ __ ] man i like
throwing around some weights i believe
in it
i really like doing jiu jitsu
but because i have
the oh the obesity hyperventilation
thing
jiu-jitsu becomes double [ __ ] hard
even when i'm when i'm in the bottom
it's hard but even when i'm on top it's
hard sometimes it's hard to breathe you
know jiu jitsu is a game of inches and
you're on top of the guy like a blanket
if i'm on top he has a blanket i still
can't [ __ ] breathe right you know i
said to you the other when he told me
you're gonna do it i was like this will
be like when you do batting practice
with the donut on the bat and then you
swing fast when you take it off
you'll do jiu-jitsu
if you lose 80 pounds 50 pounds and just
be flying
you know
the big concern is strength the big
concern is you lose a lot of muscle
tissue because of the lack of protein
okay i'll just double it up i'll just
hire john evan and just work with me
with weights every [ __ ] day for an
hour to stay on top you know he doesn't
have to stay on top of me i'll stay on
top of myself but what i'm trying to say
is somebody who
will do the weight with me you know
somebody who
when you lift heavy weights and you're
looking like you know four sets of ten
or five sets of ten or five sets of six
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing you want
somebody to push you you know you have
one set left somebody just puts their
hands up and pushes it up a little bit
so that's what i would definitely do you
know i'm looking forward to it
i can't tell you that i can't lie to you
and tell you that there's a lot of [ __ ]
i won't be able to eat ever again i
won't be able to change that grill
ever i don't think so
yeah i'll i'll go with you we'll cut in
half [ __ ] i won't be able to eat
i have a milkshake like with ice cream i
don't think you could eat sugar
i think there's so many [ __ ] things
that you just can't eat anyway
but it was time for me to say goodbye to
those things anyway i mean i've had a
good time with them and i've enjoyed
them
and i've been very good that's what
frustrates me that i could see if i was
one of those guys you know when you're
at weight watchers every week people
come in they don't lose [ __ ] right and
they're like
what do you mean i gained four pounds i
didn't eat a thing this week i drank
water oh listen come here let me talk to
you
something
and they go oh
oh my god no
it couldn't have been i went to dinner
with my friends the other night the
chichi chung and
the the poo poo plastic and you're like
that's what it was well the guide said
it was 10 calories per no but you ate 52
of them right you know when you eat 52
of them it's like anything else if you
either suggested serving your m m's
that's the bigger that's the craziest
thing if you go look
like if you go look at a bag of trail
mix there's 18 servings in it right but
how many calories per serving 100 but
like you have to have like a quarter of
a cup and normally you just put your
hand in there and throw it in your mouth
oh yeah and then you throw your hand in
there again and you throw your hand in
there again have you had the [ __ ]
trail mix from
nature box no there's one no they didn't
tell me that the cleansing
trail mix or something
oh my god it's got these chocolate stars
in them [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
diamonds and cashews and raisins
[ __ ] delicious just delicious man
sometimes you eat and that's what you
know you miss
i'm not a [ __ ] depression eater
it's like i go home and get a quarter
ice cream you know what i'm saying i
don't eat
um
i mean if i'm sad or something
what makes me happy i don't you know
chicken cutlets with mashed potatoes and
creamed corn and some cranberry juice
yeah that makes me very happy but
i don't know what it is now do you eat
fast i i've i've been noticing that's
the other thing when i'm high i just
throw it in there i've been trying to
eat slower that's the other thing that's
the other [ __ ] villain in this
[ __ ] contest
it's you eat so fast i eat so the other
day we got a sandwich by the time you
opened your wrapper i had already wolfed
it down
you took like four bites and it was gone
and you inhale it and it destroys your
stomach
they want you to chew everything 60
times so it's like a mush in your mouth
and if you do that you get tired just
from chewing
and especially with the surgery because
i only have a limited space right so
they want you to you know i won't be
able in about i think a month before the
surgery
i can't drink fluid with my
dinners until 45 minutes after i finish
eating
did you have to just eat and then drink
later dry yep oh no
it's gonna be tough so you're gonna have
to eat a lot less and different kinds of
food
nothing too salty
it's it's not you know people think oh
yeah i just go have the surgery and
that's it i'll become a [ __ ] uh
scarecrow no no
it's [ __ ] work guy yeah it's work
there's tv shows and stuff where people
don't lose the weight who have the
surgery really yeah it's called there's
a show called my 600 pound life and
they're like 700 pounds and
and if you don't exercise and you don't
eat right
because like the whole thing is like you
they shrink your stomach but if you put
too much in it that like it stretches
again
because it's the human body so if you
don't do it right it's not like it's not
like they're gonna suck it out of you do
they even have liposuction anymore could
i just go in there today and just say
like take out a hundred pounds
um i i wouldn't but do they even do that
anymore women they stick the tubes when
you suck the fat [ __ ] yeah i don't know
i bet now they have something even
better i thought they were freezing
people's fat i've seen that but i think
that's only for like love handles but
what's that what do they do
i think it's like kind of like like how
they take warts off and stuff like not
that intense but just
they they i think it's a bunch of
treatments and helps you lose like 10
pounds or something
i don't know it's another fad i'm [ __ ]
up hell yeah well you just had how many
did you have before you got here none
come on no
you always i feel like you have a
cooking job half a joint there you go i
smoked a half a joint at about four when
i woke up i had some coffee
i rolled a little bit i fed the cats i
cleaned the little boxes yeah i put the
heat on
i always love when you say to people i
haven't i haven't smoked today well tell
them what that means that means an
edible and and like two hits off but no
no no no i smoked uh
a couple pipe pulls outside when i was
drinking coffee and i wrote and that was
it i came here and i smoked that number
with you
and then i [ __ ] ate the two stars
with you that's yes but the stars hit
your [ __ ] heart these little anarchy
stars they do they hit you hard you like
you introduced me to the chef on
saturday that wasn't the chef she just
works there well i know but
i lisa she's a good [ __ ] kid this is
a great store i like this this uh
medical marijuana store it's it
the new
you know people were upset and for all
you [ __ ] haters that always send me
stupid twitch oh they're closing all the
medical marijuana stores down
they closed down the bad ones
the people that stayed open now the
people that had the original ipos
these people got to run a [ __ ] tight
[ __ ]
because i mean like it's like where i go
the herbal sound of the sunset herbal
center there
that place has three cute girls
they're [ __ ] knowledgeable
they've got
i gotta tell you they've got
30 different [ __ ] strains
they have to easy they've got three
boards they got the the sativa board
the indica board they got the [ __ ] uh
hybrid board then they got the pr board
which is the private reserve board
which is lo and then they have three
brands
that are 50 and 8 that'll kill you like
disney
uh
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know but
anyway what board do they just have a
joey diaz board i go to the last one you
know me i go right to the disney
the pr whatever there's three weeds in
that one depends something else to
perform i don't know what the [ __ ] it is
delicious
so i switch it around
i get the top three yeah and then
sometimes i [ __ ] around with the pr's
like what we smoked today was pr
skywalker
the private reserve that's what i
thought was it not good did i did i give
you some shitty weed this morning kinda
suck a [ __ ] no does it sound like you
give me [ __ ] no i give you the top of
the [ __ ] book i don't understand this
yesterday i went to the wheel the day
before and i was sitting there and i'm
out there waiting in 10 minutes and this
chick two chicks walk kind of like ha ha
i can't and what did i when i go what
these girls bought they bought a grandma
like an hour
an hour for a [ __ ] gram you go in
there you look at that girl in the face
and you go i want this [ __ ] to kill
lincoln
and they'll give you the prs or the
[ __ ] the top shelf disney or whatever
the [ __ ] they got you're buying your
[ __ ] lead they got great deals
they got phenomenal deals like the prs
they give you one gram for 15
2 grams for 20
or like two and a half grams for 25 or
something like that
it's not bad no on certain days that you
could spin the wheel and when we how
much do you smoke in a day
now yeah
a couple of jibos
couple grams you gave me a gram once i
think it lasted for like four months
you still got that weed the [ __ ]
house don't you no no it's gone now what
about the animals you had i still have
one edible left how can you have them
because they take a little bite and it
gets me high enough to fall asleep
i don't need to get i don't need to
[ __ ] get this high every every day
you're not even high right now what do
you mean in my high right now what are
you gonna do when you leave you're gonna
go to denny's and get the grand slam no
i'm gonna go home and make a bagel
and uh
that's i think i might try to take a nap
and then go about my day go to the gym
make a bagel yeah what kind of bagel do
you make cinnamon raisin it's only 200
bag when you go to the [ __ ] store and
get a fresh bagel tell me that you get
that [ __ ] from ralph's go home and toast
it i do tell me that what do you
because i know how many calories you
open up your mailbox thinking today's a
damn and i got a letter from the jews
throwing me out of the [ __ ] club
how the [ __ ] is a jewy [ __ ] bagel
because the bagels at the big place are
like 400 calories they're huge so you
want to be a jew you want to be a fake
jew which jew do you want to be i'd like
to be a religion so then you gotta eat
the real bagels guy
how the [ __ ] you you get those things
that come in a bag from robson they're
good bagels or western bagels
[ __ ] good bagels they're decent
why are you lying tell me before let me
tell you what we accept living out here
like what you accept and you go home and
you have a big one you go those ain't
[ __ ] bagels no that's true i can't
get a good poppy seed bag out here oh my
god i listen i'm stopped there's a place
on laurel king i used to go
still there whatever the bagel place is
yeah you go in there and the bagels are
[ __ ] tiny oh no
tiny you're like
hmm and they got
they got bialies and [ __ ] but i don't
even try it i i just won't [ __ ] try
it you know right that's why i'm
you know i'm ready for this move with
the gastric bypass all right the gastric
sleeve
and you know thanked felicia lampanelli
and her husband frank and you know i did
some reading and i think rosie o'donnell
did it a bunch of people had done it
after gandolfini scared a lot of people
you know we're at that age you know you
can't eat one we've had that thing that
greg and lynn gave us
that gift card yeah the gift card
and we keep saying we're gonna go we're
gonna go and you and i both know we're
gonna go and make [ __ ] animals of
ourselves you gotta go after we lift
weights and you walk from here to
[ __ ] iberian back
it's not like are they open for lunch
ah dude i don't know i'll just check
chris because maybe we'll go today up
there okay i can't work out because i
still got this little flu bug so maybe
we'll go up taking a little lunchy poo
you're in london hills yeah
uh no it's not open for lunch now they
open it uh this is what i'm saying what
the [ __ ] do these people do what are
they doing buy a 50 steak at two in the
afternoon it's not a fifty dollar state
they got lunch specials if you go to
this one where's the other place we go
morton that place do you not have a
lunch special yeah they do 1995 1495
1195 did you not see it did we not go
and do they give you chicken you want to
spend 20 you could spend 20. you want to
spend 30. you'll let you spend 30. but
if you want to spend 10 bucks at
morton's for lunchtime they [ __ ] got
it that's a beautiful thing right yeah
that's a beautiful thing i don't
understand not
you know it's like martial arts schools
you drive around you see these martial
arts schools they close but then i go on
[ __ ] uh cool coupon and they're all
on groupon
well you wouldn't have to drive your
prices if you spent some time in there
if you answered people's questions when
people have an answer about jiu jitsu or
kung fu or karate especially jiu jitsu
everybody wants to get in shape they're
going to call and i'm going to get the
machine guess where they're going to go
they're going to go to whoever answers
the phone first right that's where
they're gonna go whoever's answered the
phone and when the guy goes you know i'm
400 pounds i'm embarrassed listen come
on down i'll sit you in the back i'll
work with you
you know this will be easy i'll walk you
through it in fact since you're 400
pounds i'm gonna give you two classes
you just won that guy if you call me and
go hi joey my name is lee i'm thinking
of joining jiu jitsu
can i come down there 297 call me back
my number's three two three
that's it you lost me you lost me it's
customer service we're in a customer
service [ __ ] base world correct right
yeah
i spent 45 minutes in cvs the other day
picking up a prescription for paula with
paula and they just
they were there was only one person then
they were helping another guy and then
they did the drive-through window and
then they did the call-ins and then they
got to us it took us 45 minutes to get a
tube of some cream i go to cvs to pick
up my prescriptions and i tell you what
they pissed me off
they pissed me off a lot but they try
they always piss me off because they're
short-handed yeah they're very
short-handed they have one person at the
register who takes the prescriptions and
who teaches you the prescription like
then they have a different window that
you stand on
and then they have another window that
you take the prescriptions and she's the
same chick and the chick that's behind
the counter making the prescriptions she
don't do dick she don't want to answer
the phone she don't want to [ __ ] do
nothing so you stand there
so for some people customer service
means your guts right you know that's
what i said if i'm in front of you and
you're on the [ __ ] phone you're
slipping because i'm in front of you
with cash in my [ __ ] pocket ready to
give it to you because they used to have
like mom and pop pharmacies like you
didn't have to go to like a chain they
used to be just like a pharmacy on the
corner right right i never experienced
that joe the farmer joel whatever the
farmer when i was a kid there was a one
across the street from hashways a
pharmacy yeah it's still there and i
knew the guy the guy would go to the bar
we were kids and we'd talk to him and
stuff but i met him at the bar and years
later
i had a doctor that would give us
crooked prescriptions
and he would give me a prescription for
steroids my friend darius was dead
and i would have to call him and go hey
man i'm getting this prescription but
it's really enough you know i would see
him and he go why do you need step
rights for those steroids are kind of
being not for me he never said nothing
tell me the guy was really cool he's
like he goes i'll get you something
different tell your friend to come see
me you know it was local pharmacists
they were cool in those days there
wasn't something dea didn't have a count
on pills
right you know you can move some pills
here and then now you're responsible for
everything you're responsible for every
[ __ ] cotton ball you're responsible i
mean it's amazing because people have
[ __ ] abused it right you know people
have abused the [ __ ] system let's do
some shout outs
and let's see what the [ __ ] is going on
here today
happy birthday to my man tommy heater
the sandman andrew nandell
john shaw cleo
larry davis i hate matt
uh talking lair which we have a gofundme
for talking there he's a friend of the
podcast he's a friend of the families
and he got sick and i still haven't seen
the gofundme yeah it's it's up it's on
my twitter let me find the uh
the link for you right now
john carrasso
justin granowski here we go
and my man sandman again he's a good
[ __ ] dude a lot of people we raised a
lot over 1100 bucks in like in like
three days
it's it's on my twitter it's on steve
simone's twitter but it's easy it's
gofundme.com jv02kw
uh
listen it's january 12th
things are [ __ ] tough out there that
tough for everybody i talked to my
brother this morning on the drive here
things are tough in some parts of the
country the country's dead till [ __ ]
the snow leaves which is in march nobody
wants to make a move nobody wants to
spend money
everybody wants to see what lawyer you
know
uh this talking leg kid what's his real
name larry larry is a good guy i've had
the pleasure of meeting him three or
four times in vegas
we were gonna do breakfast last time you
know we stayed up till four in the
morning
uh
a dollar
probably listen to the podcast this
guy's not some guy on twitter that's
running some fake [ __ ] gofundme this
is some kid that's sick and needs our
help he's not even looking for much no
right you said he's looking for a
thousand bucks
his mom
two thousand bucks he didn't even i
don't even know if he knows about it
he he's been everywhere there's a lot of
great people on twitter like renee yeah
we just came out we have a lot of great
people on this network we all we all
there's a lot of people that open up
grain and they disappear there's
[ __ ]
there's people that's family uh larry
has been our family since day one
listen like i said i know it's tough
i'm not asking you all to put 150 in
there and be a big shot and put your
name up there's no need for that this
guy's looking for two dimes looking for
two g's if we each give him a dollar
it's fine so
i just want to put it out there for you
guys i know times are tough
someday when you're in a bind you know
you hit me on the side and i'll let you
you know every day i see these people
retweet from my little girl retweet for
this and i hear a lot of those things
[ __ ] you know i'm sure some of them
are i hear a lot of those things are
[ __ ] but then we did it like a year
ago uh with uh the guy i forget his
twitter name who lost his house there's
been a couple yeah he was good he still
says hello from time to time i know
you're talking about duster what's his
name he's crazy yeah he's crazy yeah no
no if you're part of our network if
you're part of my family for sure our
family will definitely help you we
always have help for you it's the people
who just go to twitter and then you go
to that site and they hit everybody out
yeah they've hit everybody up they've
hit 200 people up and they'll make money
they take it and run if it's one of us
if it's one of the people listen to the
church if you hit me and leah in the
correct [ __ ] manner i guarantee you
we will help you out in more ways than
one
today i'm asking you for talking leia
aka larry did you see his mom
is hysterical she calls me mr sai which
drives me nuts but then like everyone's
writing on the on the comments
everyone's like uh like tammy did it but
then somebody was like church hummus and
she was like i was reading through the
comments and i don't really know much
about this church but you must have a
really caring minister
because she's actually religious um
let me see if i can find out where it's
his minister but it just it made me
laugh so hard but it it just it was
really cool i put it out on twitter and
i it just it was it was awesome that
people really helped out you know this
is what it's about this why do this [ __ ]
that we do why do this
tweet it to me so when i go home i can
put some money on his books i'll tweet
it right now so we get the party started
here and that's basically it guys you
know it's monday the 12th we want to do
an old-fashioned in the morning
uh if you guys don't don't know and i'll
be on the rogan podcast this afternoon
at two o'clock
but i'm happy we got this one out of the
way you know let me give some shout outs
to our sponsors and get this
few [ __ ] who don't know i'm
gonna be at the helium comedy club in
buffalo
next thursday the 22nd and the week
after that super bowl [ __ ] weekend
i'm gonna be at my main place the funny
bone in [ __ ] columbus ohio so
lee
give them the nfl perspective this is
the nfl perspective from lisa yeah what
do you think
uh uh
i was surprised i'm a little [ __ ]
nervous this morning oh well i was
pissed off during the patriots game i
did change shirts but uh
i was i thought we're gonna lose to the
ravens i was sure we're gonna lose i was
surprised peyton manning lost
he really had a bad last few weeks and
they said he had two thigh injuries so i
don't know if he just all of a sudden
got really old or he just hurt that
really i would have liked to have face
peyton manning it's like i don't know
who cares about facing andrew luck like
i i'm he's they're a great team but
brady manning is a great game uh
green bay versus seattle should be a
cool game i i i would never know how to
pick that game
[ __ ] green bay killed us but then
seattle won super bowl last year
so
i'd love to see
patriots green bay patriot seattle i
don't think anybody really wants to see
the coal i mean i know indianapolis
people want to see them but if you're
looking for like tv ratings like that
that patriots baltimore game that was
like the highest rated tv like playoff
game and tv show had like a 20 rating or
something great [ __ ] game yeah listen
it's a good game i'll sit there i was
trying to watch it i kept going back and
forth i had the baby that afternoon my
wife went to some right uh party and i
had that baby and i was trying to watch
and i could tell
i had the makings you know anytime you
have tom brady with him with his back
against the wall yeah he he's either
gonna [ __ ] you up or he's gonna oh he's
gonna tap out this was a great he
because we didn't have any running game
i think they ran like seven times other
than his and two of them were his qb
runs i felt bad for dallas
that that call yesterday seemed tough
but i didn't watch the game
you're from the boston area we have a
lot of church people from the boston
area
so when does the aaron hernandez try
soon soon it's getting his and the
terrorist kid that one's already started
the terrorist kids already started so
they're both gonna be in boston they're
saying it's gonna be i don't know where
the
where the aaron i think the aaron
hernandez one is gonna be because yeah
cause i have people going in there and
and patriots jerseys go go patriots and
of course they get kicked out um
but it's uh that's pretty it's pretty
sad
like that that's something like we've
talked about it like i don't unders i
couldn't understand signing a 60 million
dollar contract and then going and
shooting a guy because he talked to the
wrong people because i want to be a
gangster is that what happened yeah he
he signed us like a four-year contract
why did he shoot this particular kid
apparently he didn't like how he was
talking he was talking to the wrong
people at a club or something i don't
know he sounds like apparently he shot
two more people a couple years before
that
because they were they
they were rude to him at a club or
something or or they were they bumped
into him
it was just
if it's true if this is if it's all true
which it sounds like it probably is
he's he was just a monster
well we'll [ __ ] see you know we had
two uh we had a big hit last week with
jon jones yeah a lot of people couldn't
believe it you know a lot of people look
for me to jokes and it's it's [ __ ]
sad it was very sad to me i'm not mad at
john or whatever
i had heard the rumors really i heard
the rumors i had heard the rumors the
last couple months i don't know
there was a an interview i think in
bloody elbow where the guy said that uh
the rumors have been swirling for a
while
i didn't would you see it and i wouldn't
see it to be honest until somebody might
say to me when he was in l.a last time
all the times he was trying to cop but
at first i was like oh my god and then i
heard it a second time
i never told joe but like i said i told
hari at the before the fight friday
night after the show at the mirage we
saw jon jones i told ari
and when he came up positive ah he
called me right away and said i don't
believe it i told you
where there's smoke there's fire people
just don't make that type of [ __ ] up you
know right my heart goes out to him and
his family so i did some research today
apparently if the
the drug test he did before the fight
comes back positive then he could lose
right but that that's not coming back
has it come back negative yet i don't
know because i read because i was just
doing some research because everyone was
like oh well nick diaz got suspended for
a year apparently
that was because he tested positive in
competition
so if you even if you test positive out
of competition for weed it it'd be
treated the same way that's the way i
read the art i think the ufc has to lay
a punishment because it's uh
part of uh code and conduct i don't
think they're going to
you know what i all right now is that i
hope he gets better i hope he uh i know
what it is to be in that position
i know what it is to have everything you
know i i had everything in boulder and i
didn't want it you know i had a baby in
the room my wife
had in-laws who loved me i just bought a
condo
and i didn't want it i know what it's
like to sneak cocaine to feel that you
need it
so i hope he uh
takes that
pain away the the pain of needing it so
you don't look it's not uh performance
enhancing in any way to you cocaine
right cocaine
listen
for me look at when you smoke pot what
do you feel like doing it
taking a nap any cheeseburger when i
smoke pot i want to take a notebook out
i want to read a book if the sun's
shining i want to [ __ ]
go out there enjoy the day when i first
started smoking pot
i knew i didn't like being inside but i
also liked listening to music but once i
got the invention of the i whatever the
[ __ ] i play the the walkman
it made life easier when i get high i
want to
adventure
i want to go out i want to take a chance
i want to get really high i want to see
different people okay i want to see
different situations
you don't like seeing that no you know
when some people do cocaine they get
very
uh extroverted is that the word what's
introverted when you introverted me
being inside alone okay extroverted
you're out you're talking you're
drinking
that's the way it started for me but it
became something else i became very
introverted with the drug
when i was locked up in prison we used
to do speed on mondays and try to play
basketball
oh my [ __ ] god you have no idea
you have no idea what it was like
your heart feels like it's gonna fly to
your [ __ ] mouth that's what it feels
like
it's like adding gasoline to a fire you
know like a fire is burning and also
you're running
you know when you don't need to run did
it enhance my performance i think i ran
i could play eight or nine [ __ ] games
maybe help my cardio but that was speed
cocaine is something different it
affects your mind a different way
it [ __ ] with like your happiness
[ __ ] juice or something like that
doesn't it like you're i forget the name
of the serotonin serotonin or whatever i
think when you crash it does when you
cry
listen i don't know i can't
i remember i used to think of people
saying well lawrence taylor has to be
good he probably does blow when he plays
football i don't see it
if he did god bless him
god bless him if one day in one of his
books he says i used to do it i eat ball
and go out there and i realized i
tackled more people
god bless him but between you and i i
never found nothing
that cocaine enhanced
nothing
i said on stage the other day march 17
1992
i did cocaine and went on stage saint
patty's day i wasn't even doing comedy a
year yet and i thought the same thing i
go i'll do two bumps of coke and go up
there and rip these [ __ ] a new
[ __ ]
boy was i wrong brother yeah boy did i
eat [ __ ] because it blocks the heart
so all you're getting are words but that
was me maybe richard pryor killed on it
you know i don't know if kennison did
well but the shows i saw
on tape and youtube mechanism was coked
out he didn't do that well he did well
because people were yelling and people
thought being high was cool
you know when you go see artie lang
years ago and he was [ __ ] up it wasn't
by no means hilarious artie's a funny
[ __ ] guy but i remember seeing him in
vegas with the preacher
and a bunch of guys and we all went we
all left because it was so [ __ ] bad
but to the people who go see that
they'll pay 50 to see you [ __ ] up on
stage and white crystals falling out of
your nose how do i know because i did it
for years in miami
people would want to come see me [ __ ]
up they'd tell me afterward that was
great
you said the joke twice
you know i don't [ __ ] get it but
for fighting
i can't see it
i can't see doing a line of coke and
running down that thing and having john
mccarthy touch you
or herb dean touch you and search you
down and you go in there with your heart
being like that i can't [ __ ] see it
and let's say it's a five-round [ __ ]
fight
you come down in 20 minutes really
that's fast yeah you come down in 20
minutes
maybe the
the whatever what do they call when the
juice that runs adrenaline maybe that
kicks it up which it probably does but i
can't see i i just don't see it
i just don't see it if it works for jon
jones
god [ __ ] bless him i just think
the part people most people have a
problem with is that if it was a new
fighter
he'd probably be out of the ufc already
he would have been out of the ufc listen
before the news came out you know i
can't believe that we listened to this
podcast for two years and all of the
podcasts and people get illuminated to
what the ufc is about or what they're
not about you don't understand one day
the ufc is no different than any other
[ __ ] company in the world right
they're into money okay
if if you were jon jones if you're dana
white okay
you're [ __ ] dana white and i call you
and i go hey man
jon jones tested positive on december
4th
so what does that mean that means uh he
tested positive can you cancel the fight
no it's not against he was out of
competition
it was a random ua
what do you want to do
do you want to [ __ ] cancel the fight
after the year they took that do you
really really think in your heart after
they already had the possibility dana
white was going to cancel that fight for
donald cerrone against miles jury
is that and hector lombard against
whatever is that what you think what
would he do
what would he do december 4th dale white
that's not just a card and [ __ ] some
[ __ ] sub city that's the card at the mgm
grand on new year's day what the [ __ ]
would he do do you are you people that
[ __ ] stupid that you would think dana
would go stop the card let's put him in
the rehab [ __ ] him at his [ __ ] rehab
he's fighting we'll put him on a bus to
rehab right after the fight or two days
after when he gets his yayas out and he
gets his dick stopped but we're not
gonna put him in a rehab right away you
know these are the things that people
don't understand and everybody's playing
dumb right why don't they why don't they
say something to them again it's about
money the bottom line and especially
with this usb it's about [ __ ] money
guys so if you're that [ __ ] stupid at
home oh nick beers who gives a [ __ ] nick
diaz tested positive after the fight
right is that not what the thing was if
i remember correctly in competition two
different [ __ ] worlds
two different [ __ ] worlds so suck it
in get it together and realize it's all
about the [ __ ] benjamins and that
overrules everything in 2015.
there's no rules what happened to the
people who are going to stop the
corporations and pick it up
what happened to them what happened to
them you know what happened to them the
bottom [ __ ] line
the bottom [ __ ] line
they can't cancel it you don't like jon
jones i don't know what the [ __ ] to tell
you
you don't like the way the rules are
[ __ ] done i don't know what the [ __ ]
to tell you do you know they don't test
the thc in basketball
really no
because every [ __ ] player would
[ __ ] fail
they test for coke and steroids and
everything else and the nba they don't
test for thc that's widely known
take it at least you got the fight shut
your mouth let's pray to god that jon
jones gets better and let's move on with
our life that's the only thing you could
[ __ ] do hell no hey hey all right
then
on it.com did they check his blood maybe
he was on honor.com also
maybe he was on [ __ ] alpha brain
maybe he was on shroom tech [ __ ]
sport maybe that's [ __ ] dirty [ __ ]
whatever but whatever it was
this is what we do you give the guy a
[ __ ] chance go to honor.com see what
they got to offer you you know what
honor is not a vitamin
is not a [ __ ] one a day honor is for
you to be the best that you could
[ __ ] be that's why you go to on it
you start off with alphabet i'm not
going to [ __ ] tell you again they got
so many great products if you don't go
to honor right now when you're at work
they're paying you right who gives a
[ __ ] go to honda.com look at the
products they got you just sitting there
with a thumb up your [ __ ] ass read
about the [ __ ] minerals
read about the coconut oil read about
the [ __ ] shroom tech sport read about
the shroom tech commune see if it's for
you you know what it is for you because
you're going to be the best that you
[ __ ] can be aka
the foo fighters go to honor.com find
something try some even if it's alpha
brain go to the box and press in church
after you check out preston church and
get ten percent off your order before
you check out before you check out
you get ten percent off your order
plus if you want to do the stay on a
program you could stay on it where they
mail it directly to your house every
month you don't have to go back online
and register when they hit your credit
card i don't know how the [ __ ] they do
it but do me a favor they got the battle
ropes they got stuff they got weights
they got a bunch of stuff for you to do
plus the minerals i can't help you with
the battle ropes and that type of stuff
but the minerals are on me go to
honor.com and press in church and get 10
off your [ __ ] first order like my man
lee said before you know this week uh
cable gave away free weekends for
everybody cables channels no they're in
trouble they're trying everything they
do to get new people but the rates are
astronomical
me i've just been [ __ ] introduced to
roku
and uh netflix and all this and i gotta
tell you something i love it that
netflix has everything you [ __ ]
wanted that real cool has everything you
wanted
irondragontv.com my favorite [ __ ]
roku channel you understand me they got
every single classic martial art film
that you love from sunny chiba to early
jackie chan to the yip man series and
every day they add up new [ __ ] movies
every week they got workout movies from
on it they got different uh
i mean they are
tremendous
dave foley is working [ __ ] 24 7 to
make this roku channel one of the best
[ __ ] channels out there and it's
growing he's also got the technology on
the 4k tv and you know what's cool if
you go and check
they're converting a lot of stuff to 4k
but if you go they have a lot of stuff
that they haven't converted yet for free
so they have some free movies on there
so like if they're if they only have a
lower quality of it they put it up there
for free so so just go there and you can
see more than two movies but then
they're they're in the process of
changing that to 4k so there's some cool
free movies on there that you can watch
okay so do me a favor go to iron dragon
tv right now and press in joey in the
box and get two [ __ ] movies for free
off the bat take a look around see what
they got maybe you didn't consider
martial art movies maybe you didn't like
martial art movie the classic ones take
a look at the classic ones you're gonna
[ __ ] love them all right go to iron
dragon tv and press in joey i get you
two free movies nailed it life
if you're smoking vapor you're losing
your [ __ ] mind go to nailed it
life.com the best vapor pen on the
market they've also got some really neat
stuff for that whole world of vaping
they call it what they call yeah vaping
and they have neat stuff you know all
the [ __ ] you need to put the [ __ ]
thing in the pipe and
the thing to carry the vape they have a
ton of things plus t-shirts go to nailed
it com right now and press in joey diaz
and get 20 percent off your first order
okay listen off your vapor pen i'm
telling you high quality guarantee you
got a problem you call dave they hook
you right the [ __ ] up there's no games i
wouldn't be working with them if they
were fugazi go to nailed it in life.com
and also for you bad [ __ ] out
there trying to get your health in order
i see a lot of you guys have taken it
i'm done you give it a shot
hitysigs.com hit these things as [ __ ]
vapor cigarettes that'll knock you
through a [ __ ] loop you understand me
they come in different flavors not to
mention they come in different grades 24
milligrams 16 milligrams 8-0 if you're
looking to quit smoking dog so you start
with the 24 within a month you'll be on
the zero they also have a [ __ ] cigar
you can blow smokes at casinos if you go
to atlantic city you could blow up the
asians faces you know what i'm saying
i just won this chino anyway go to
86.com and what did i get lee you get 20
off when you use code joey's church
that's right so usually 20 to get it for
16. give it a try you're not going to be
[ __ ] sorry
guaranteed 1200 puffs you know how many
pumps when you buy those things over the
counter in the [ __ ] store how many
you get done nothing this will last you
two weeks even if you're a heavy [ __ ]
smoker go to 86.com give them a try tom
joey sent you i want to thank on it i
want to thank iron dragon i want to
thank nailed it life i want to thank
kitty cigs and i want to thank all you
[ __ ] for waking up and
listening to the show and giving us love
on every aspect that we got like i said
i'm gonna be in helium buffalo in two
weeks and i'm also gonna be at the
columbus funny bone
super bowl weekend [ __ ] oh yeah
we forgot to say we had some cause i was
thinking when you were doing the hidey
sigs that how everyone always asks you
if they act if they work for for
quitting smoking what you've done yeah
but another guy we had we had some crazy
uber drivers on on wednesday
we we had a guy who
you told you were a a political prisoner
from cuba oh my god for the entire idea
like man i came from cuba i've been here
for 30 years i'm a political refugee
though two those are two of the cute
coolest uber drivers we ever met and the
way donna was an old russian dude it was
cool as [ __ ] he kept thinking i was big
[ __ ] on the way back we had an egyptian
pizza maker and also made italian food
he was an egyptian dude i made greek
food an italian chef no it was italian
mexican and like from the netherlands
like dutch food he was an egyptian and i
just saw your face
and then you just kept asking him
questions about it he was a [ __ ]
sweetheart dog and he left a wife in
egypt yeah he left his wife in asia you
know these stories are amazing when you
get to talk to people
sometimes they're very interesting some
people are douche bags but if you give
them a chance they're very sweet both of
these guys are very sweet
and then you got me high i think the
next night
on the way home from long beach and the
cops stopped in front of us like there's
an accident the cops stopped the entire
highway oh that's right oh so we got
high in long beach and we were driving
and like four cop suvs stopped in a line
ahead of us and they stopped for like 20
minutes and i was stoned out of my mind
and you after like five minutes you open
up the center console and you start
taking joints out
i'm filming it i'm filming it with the
with the sirens lights like ten feet in
front of us and you smoking on a joint
and then like you started beeping at him
and i got paranoid so i had deleted the
video the [ __ ] video guys i was like
that cops are gonna come the cop's gonna
pull him over and take his [ __ ]
camera can you believe this in this day
and age
[ __ ] i can't breathe get it together
i love you guys thank you very much for
listening have a great week we'll see
you wednesday night with the great barry
cats in [ __ ] studio that's one
of the best podcasts we did last year he
called it i can't imagine how
knowledgeable he's going to be so
wednesday night eight o'clock we'll be
back here again on it iron dragon tv
nailed it life
hit e6 but most importantly to you
[ __ ] for letting us come into
your world every week uh twice a week
and giving me and lee all the love you
can
that's it have a great week your dreams
are right in front of you tell them all
to suck your dick
and go for it [ __ ]
what lee what what lee
i would love to tell somebody to suck my
deck that'd be fun tell them
let's go to denny's okay
this show is brought to you by
honest.com go to honor danny's
why are you messing with me i would love
to go to dinners right now those
communist eggs
why are they communist eggs because
they're not real like you don't get
healthy from those
okay
don't go to denny's go to onyx.com use
cohort church to get ten percent off of
all the great optimization products
alpha brain new moods from tech immune
stream tech sport it's code word church
to get ten percent off
go to uh hit e6 dot com that's hitler e6
dot com and he's covered joey's church
to get 20 off better tasting longer
lasting the proof is in the vape they
have e-cigarettes and e-cigars for you
you get 20 off when you use cobra joey's
church
go to nailed it life.com and use
codeword joey diaz to get 20 off of the
premier vapor pair on the market for all
the oil and wax smokers out there
and go to iron dragon tv
and use cobourg joey to get two free
rentals of all of the great martial arts
movies they have the 4k technology
coming they're gonna you're gonna be
able to stream to your android uh
tablets pretty soon it's cobra joey get
two free rentals